ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAKER
PORGES CABALLERO CORTES E.
DALLEY DODD TORONTO EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ HERTZBERG WEST
SO HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYARD LEYVA LIMON MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
TROUBLED PAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER. KERN NUMBER WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WILK. MEMBERS
OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY-PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
PENN AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AS WE WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE OF THE
FLAG. I SENATOR MEN. PRESIDENT.
LET'S PRAY HOLY MYSTERY AS WE
CELEBRATE ANOTHER LUNAR NEW YEAR
THE YEAR OF THE TIGER. HELP US
TO LIVE INTO THIS NEW YEAR WITH
QUALITIES OF THE TIGER. COURAGE
BUT WE STEP OUT OF OUR COMFORT
ZONES AND CHALLENGE THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT KEEP US IN
BONDAGE TO HESITANCY AND FEAR.
STRENGTH MAY WE FOLLOW THROUGH
THE COMPLEX OUR DESIRES FOR
HARMONY TRUTH AND JUSTICE.
RESILIENCE MAY WE PERSEVERE AND
HOPE AND CONFIDENCE THAT THE
TRANSFORMATION OF OUR SOCIETY
WILL COME TO PASS FOR THE SAKE
OF FUTURE GENERATIONS. WE ASK
THIS IN YOUR NAME A MAN. SB ON
THE RAIL PLEASE JOIN ME THAT BY
THE WAY. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO
THE FLAG. ONE IS. MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE SENATORS BATES BRADFORD
AND GROW PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
SENATORS. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. SENATOR ATKINS. MEMBERS
IF I COULD ASK YOU TO PLEASE SIT
DOWN AND PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
PLEASE AS WE HONOR. STAFF AND
OTHER MEMBERS. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- I AM JUST
PERSONALLY AND- THRILLED AND
PROFESSIONALLY THRILLED AS A
SENATOR TO WELCOME UP TO THE
GALLERY. ZELDA SOMERVILLE BY TO
OUR SENATE FLOOR TODAY NOW I
KNOW THAT ALL OF YOU KNOW HER
QUITE WELL. BECAUSE OVER THE
COURSE OF THIRTY TWO YEARS WITH
THE SENATE OFFICE OF
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS. WHICH
ITSELF IS ONLY THIRTY FOUR YEARS
OLD AS ELDER WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
SHAPING THE OFFICE AND THUS IN
ESTABLISHING CALIFORNIA AS A
LEADER ON THE INTERNATIONAL
STAGE. SHE LED SENATE
DELEGATIONS TO OVER FORTY
COUNTRIES AND SPEARHEADED OUR
EFFORTS TO CREATE AND STRENGTHEN
PURPOSEFUL CONNECTIONS ON EVERY
POPULATED CONTINENT. CONNECTIONS
THAT ARE CRUCIAL TO OUR STATE
STANDING AS THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY I THINK WE ALL
KNOW WE ARE WELL RECEIVED ONLY
TRAVEL BECAUSE OF HOW PEOPLE
VIEW CALIFORNIA. ZELDA TOOK THAT
MISSION VERY SERIOUSLY AND
PERSONALLY. FROM HER FIRST DAYS
AS AN OFFICE ASSISTANT TO HER
FINAL ONES AS THE DIRECTOR. AS
ELDER BECAME WIDELY RESPECTED BY
OUR INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS. AND
PROVED TO BE INEFFECTUAL
DIPLOMATIC AGENT WITH AN
UNRELENTING WORK ETHIC.
FORTUNATELY FOR THE SENATOR SHE
LED AROUND THE WORLD HER ABILITY
TO STAY CALM UNDER PRESSURE IS
ALSO UNRELENTING. IF YOU THINK
TRAVELING WITH YOUR FAMILY IS
CHAOTIC YOU SHOULD TALK TO IS
OLDER ABOUT THE TIME OUR
DELEGATIONS LUGGAGE WAS LOST IN
JAPAN. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US RETRIEVE IT AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR HELPING US KEEP
OUR HEADS. THERE ARE LIMITLESS
STORIES ABOUT A CELL THE GUIDING
US THROUGH I OPENING EXPERIENCE
IN INTERESTING SITUATIONS. I
PERSONALLY SAW IN JAPAN INDIA
BHUTAN AND RUSSIA. WE CELEBRATED
HER BIRTHDAY. AND I KNOW OTHERS
HAVE STORIES OF THEIR OWN. IT
WAS ALSO WITH HER SUPPORT THAT
WE WELCOME DIGNITARIES FROM
AROUND THE WORLD TO CALIFORNIA.
OUR ABILITY TO SERVICE BOTH
GUEST AND HOST WAS ENHANCED BY
HER PREPARATION HER KNOWLEDGE
AND HER POSITIVE ATTITUDE. IT'S
WITH THE GREATEST RELUCTANCE-
THAT I SAY GOODBYE TO THIS
REMARKABLE MEMBER OF OUR SENATE
FAMILY. AS SHE BEGINS HER NEXT
CHAPTER I AM SURE THAT HER
HUSBAND CRAIG- I BELIEVE I SAW
ON THE GALLERY TODAY ALONG WITH
HER. AS WELL AS HER SONS RYAN
AND STEWART WILL GREATLY
APPRECIATE HAVING HER AROUND
MORE. AND A THE OLDER ONES
COALBED HOPEFULLY SIMMERS DOWN
IN THIS BEHIND US YOU CAN TRAVEL
WITH THEM AND ENJOY A NOT
KEEPING TABS ON GROUP OF JETLAG
SENATORS AND ARE WONDERING
LUGGAGE. SO COLLEAGUES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THANKING IS ALL THE
SOME OF THE- FOR THIRTY TWO
YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR
ATKINS BENEFITS ONE LAST COMMENT
IF I MAY. AT THE REQUEST OF A
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY THEY ASK IS ALL THE
PLEASE DO NOT WRITE A BOOK. I
WHAT CONGRATULATIONS ON- AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE SENATE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MAN PRESIDENT- TODAY WE ARE.
HONORING EARNED RICHEST THE- NOW
RECENTLY RETIRED- CHIEF
CONSULTANT OF THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE- SOMEONE WHO WE
ALREADY- MESS SHE REALLY HAS
THIS IS AN AMAZING AMAZING OUR
PUBLIC SERVANTS AND A STAFFER
FOR MANY YEARS I NEARLY THREE-
YOU KNOW THIRTY YEARS WORKING IN
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE CAPITAL.
OUR COMMUNITY BYRON STARTED HER
CAREER IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE
WORKING FOR A SPEAKER WILLIE
BROWN SHE WENT ON TO WORK FOR
SEVERAL ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
INCLUDING ASSEMBLY MINORITY
LEADER RICHARD KATZ AND MICHAEL
SWEENEY. FOCUSING ON MANAGED
CARE CHILD SUPPORT LIQUOR
LICENSES AND HOUSING- OF NOTE I
SEE BOTH STARTED HER CAREER AND
ENDED HER CAREER WORKING- FOR A
SAN FRANCISCAN SHE JUST COULDN'T
GET ENOUGH OF OUR GREAT CITY-
FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN- AND WAS A POLICY
ANALYST. FOR THENONPROFIT
CALIFORNIA BUDGET PROJECT
WORKING ON HOUSING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES. SHE THEN WENT ON TO WORK
AT THE SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
WHERE SHE CONTINUED HER FOCUS ON
HOUSING LOCAL GOVERNMENT. LAND
WELL AS RESEARCHING
INCRIMINATORY L. TWENTY CAME
BEFORE THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR CONFIRMATION- ARE
ENJOYING THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING COMMITTEE
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AS A
PRINCIPAL CONSULTANTS. ONE OF
HER BIGGEST ACCOMPLISHMENTS WAS
BEING PART OF THE ENATE TEAM
ARE WORKING TO PASS WHAT BECAME.
UNCERTAIN MANY MANY YEARS
COLLEAGUES AS YOU'LL RECALL A TO
GET TO THE POINT WHERE WE CAN
PASS THAT TRANSFORMATIONAL- I
TURN OF TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
MEASURE- BUILD WAS AUTHORED BY
SENATOR BELL I'M PASSED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN- SHE ALSO
HELPED TO CREATE AN ADVANCED
MITIGATION PROGRAM WHICH HELPS
SPEED THE COMPLETION OF. ROAD
PROJECTS WHAT BETTER PROTECTING
HAVE A TIME. UNTIL NINETEEN. THE
TERM HOUSING WAS INTO COMMIT I
SHOULD HIM OVER- TO WORK WITH US
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE-
WHERE SHE BECAME THE CONSULTANTS
- IN ADDITION TO HER ROLES TO
CONSULTANTS WHO WORKED ON
VARIOUS BILLS RELATING TO
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
HOMELESSNESS HOUSING FINANCE
SURPLUS LANDS ACT- BUILDING
STANDARDS WILDFIRES HOUSING
ELEMENTS- AND- INTERESTING H.
AWAY BILLS WHICH IS ARE ALWAYS
THE MOST POPULAR BILLS IN THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE- BUT I
SERIOUSLY- AND JUST HAD THE HAS
IS BREATH OF EXPERTISE. AND
KNOWLEDGE AND SO MANY. AREAS OF
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND I
THINK COLLEAGUES WE SOMETIMES-
IT'S EASY TO TAKE FOR GRANTED
WITH OUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
PEOPLE WHO JUST HAVE SUCH.
PARKWAY ENCYCLOPEDIA KNOWLEDGE-
AND THEN WHEN THEY'RE GONE ALSO
YOU REALIZE HOW MUCH KNOWLEDGE
THEY HAD AND HOW MUCH WE TOOK
THAT KNOWLEDGE. FOR GRANTED
FORTUNATELY ERNEST ALL AROUND
AND WE WILL CALL HER HAVE BEEN
CALLING HER WILL CONTINUE TO
CALL HER LIBERALLY AND BUG HER
AND HER RETIREMENT AS WE- TRY TO
NAVIGATE- SO MANY ARE
CHALLENGING AND COMPLICATED
HOUSING- ISSUES IN THE SENATE.
HI AND I ALSO JUST WANNA KNOW
AND THIS IN THE BEGINNING AND
ENDING HER CAREER WORKING FOR A
SAN FRANCISCAN- HER FIRST CHAIR.
AND HER LAST YEAR HAD THE SAME
CHIEF OF STAFF SO- AND-
DEFINITELY CAME FULL CIRCLE IN.
A VARIOUS CONTACTS BY INTO
RETIREMENT EARNS BEEN SPENDING
TIME WITH HER PARTNER PAUL.
RETIRED FROM THE ASSEMBLY A YEAR
AGO ANDERSON JIMMY RIGHT HERE BY
COMPLAIN GOLF SHE ALSO HOPES TO
SPEND MORE TIME TRAVELING SO-
AND WE MISS YOU ALREADY- AND WE
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST AND THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR DECADES. OF
SERVICE TO THIS GREAT
INSTITUTION.
THANK YOU TO YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE SENATE
HOUSING HAS CONTINUED TO BE ONE
OF THE MOST INTRACTABLE ISSUES
THAT WE DEAL WITH SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPERTISE AND
WE- YOU WILL BE MISSED. CENTERS
MOVING ON TO SENATOR- CHOI BOGUE. THE BORDERS THE MORNING MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. THIS
MORNING WE RECOGNIZE OUR AS THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE I'M HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE ROGER MALCOLMSON WHO
RETIRED IN DECEMBER AFTER
WORKING IN THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES
. ROGER BEGAN A LIFETIME OF
PUBLIC SERVICE WHEN HE ENLISTED
IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY AT THE
TENDER AGE OF SEVENTEEN. AND WAS
ASSIGNED TO THE THIRD U. S.
INFANTRY REGIMENT. FOLLOWING HIS
HONORABLE DISCHARGE HE COMPLETED
HIS UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE AT UC
DAVIS AND EARNED HIS MASTER'S
DEGREE AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY. HE JOINED THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS AS A FISCAL
CONSULTANT WORKING ON EDUCATION
ISSUES IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE.
AND MOVED TO THE POLICY OFFICE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO WHERE HE
ANALYZED APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND EDUCATION RELATED BILLS
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES. I HAD
THE PLEASURE WORKING WITH ROGER
DURING MY FIRST YEAR IN THE
SENATE LAST YEAR WHEN SERVING AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. HIS COMMITMENT TO HIS
WORK CHAU THROUGH HIS WELL
CRAFTED ANALYSIS AND BRIEFINGS.
HE WORKED HIS WORK HELPED ME
BETTER UNDERSTAND ISSUES
ALLOWING YOU TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS FOR THE GREATER GOOD.
ROGER YOUR DEDICATION HEART AND
HARD WORK WILL BE MISSED YOU
HAVE FOREVER IMPACTED THE LIVES
OF EVERY CALIFORNIAN. THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT YOU HAVE MADE
TO OUR STATE ARE IMMEASURABLE
YOU HAVE TRULY BEEN ONE OF THE
PILLARS OF THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
AND OUR SUCCESS CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR RETIREMENT.
SENATOR
LEYVA. DID YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR GROW. THANK
YOU I'M MADAM PRESIDENT AT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RISE TODAY TO
HONOR A MAN WHO'S KNOWN TO SO
MANY OF US YOUR HIS LIFELONG
DEVOTION AND- SURVEEN OUR STATE
COUNTRY AND OUR COUNTRY ROGER
MACKENSEN AS THE EDUCATION
POLICY CONSULTANT ROGER HAS A
YES AND FOR MAKING EVEN THE MOST
MUNDANE DETAILS INTERESTING AND
ENGAGING AND HE'S KNOWN AND FOR
HIS VERY WITTY REMARKS THAT HE
PUTS ON HIS AND ALICE'S IGNORED
IN THE EDUCATION. COMMITTEE ON
HIS BILLS IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
ABLE TO RECOGNIZE ROGER FOR HIS
DEVOTION TO PUBLIC SERVICE IN
LISTING IN THE ARMY AT SEVENTEEN
BEING A MEMBER OF THE CON ALERT
GUARD HONORING OUR FLAG OUR
TRADITIONS REPRESENTING OUR
NATION AND THE ARMED FORCES IN
MAKING PEOPLE CROWD IN. THE
BEAUTIFUL STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ROGERS TIME IN RENO AN INTER
UNDER GOD WILSON TO WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR SHALL DEVELOPMENT
OF EDUCATION OFFICE ALL OF THIS
IN INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE FORMED
A SOLID BEDROCK. UPON WHICH HE
BUILT TWENTY TWO YEARS A VALUED
AND TRUSTED SERVICE AS A
CONSULTANT FOR THE SENATE.
ROGERS EXPERIENCE AND DEDICATION
TO MEANINGFUL EDUCATION POLICIES
AND NOW IT HOW THEY AFFECT OUR
STATE AS A WHOLE IS REMARKABLE.
HE'S BEEN AND IT'S BEEN AN HONOR
AND A PLEASURE GETTING TO KNOW
HIM IN PERSONALLY AND IN
SPENDING TIME WITH HIM AND
COUNCIL ON EDUCATION BILLS
WORKING WITH HIM WHILE I WAS IN
LEADERSHIP. IS ONE OF THE FIRST
PEOPLE TO JUMP IN AND HELP WITH
ANYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
ON A DESTRUCTIVE ISSUE NO ISSUE
OR ANY QUESTION RELATED TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S HISTORY. HE'S
ALWAYS BEEN A HARD WORKING
CONSULTANT DEDICATING HOURS ON
IN ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR-
MEMBERS ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
OF THE I'LL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE THE EXACT INFORMATION WE
NEED TO MAKE IT POLICY
DECISIONS. WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION ROGER IS ALWAYS READY
TO HELP HE'S ALWAYS THE FIRST TO
LEND A HAND ESPECIALLY WITH
JUNIOR STAFF. HE HAS A LIFETIME
OF KNOWLEDGE IN OUR BUILDING AND
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT G. STAFF
WHEN THEY COME IN UNDERSTANDING
HISTORY IN THE INTEGRITY OF THE
INSTITUTION AND HOW. THINGS
WORK. IS THE FIRST TO TAKE TIME
WHICH TO ENSURE STAFF UNDERSTAND
ALL THE INS AND OUTS OF COMPLEX
ISSUES. ESPECIALLY ADMIRE HOW HE
INSTILLS SELF CONFIDENCE AND
OTHERS AND MAKES PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN ACCOMPLISH
ANYTHING. THAT HE FOR HIM.
ROGERS A. J. PERSON. AND NOT
ONLY DO HE ENTERED. HOW THE
INSTITUTE OPERATES. BUT HE IS
ALSO ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS MOST VALUED
MEMBER. AND HE KNOWS HOW THE
SYSTEM SHOULD INCLUDE WORK TO
BENEFIT ALL OF OUR CHILDREN.
ROGER OUR CHILDREN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND YOUR
EXPERTISE. ON ALL OF THESE
EDUCATION ISSUES. MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR WHEN SAID
INTELLIGENCE PLUS CHARACTER.
THAT IS THE GOAL OF A TRUE
EDUCATION. ROGER WITH YOUR
INTELLIGENCE AND CHARACTER
CHARACTER YOU EXEMPLIFY HOW
EDUCATE THING CAN ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL. THE LEGACY YOU LEAVE
BEHIND WHAT IMPACT THE LIVES OF
OUR CHILDREN FOR YEARS TO COME.
NOW I KNOW I'VE HEARD AND THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE TRAVELING A BIT.
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
RIDING YOUR BIKE AND I THINKING
EVEN HURT A LITTLE BIT OF
VOLUNTEER WORKERS POSSIBLY IN
YOUR FUTURE. I JUST WANT TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT YOU ARE ALWAYS
WELCOME BACK INTO THE HALLS OF
THIS BUILDING. FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING AND YOU WILL ALWAYS
ALWAYS BE WELCOME WITH OPEN ARMS
THANK YOU AGAIN SIR IF YOU'RE
DEDICATED TWENTY TWO YEARS OF
SERVICE. TO OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
STATE MAY GOD BLESS YOU AND
GUIDE YOU THROUGH THIS NEXT
CHAPTER YOUR- FOR NEARLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS ROGER WE'RE GOING TO
MISS YOU SO MUCH AND SENATE
EDUCATION- YOU THIS IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE I HAVE CHAIRED SO YOU
WERE THE FIRST REPUBLICAN
CONSULTANT THAT I HAVE WORKED
WITH AND LET ME JUST SAY THE NEW
PERSON HAS BIG SHOES TO FOLLOW
OUR TO FILL BECAUSE YOU JUST
MADE IT SO EASY EVEN ON
DIFFICULT ISSUES I APPRECIATE
HOW YOU WORK WITH MY TEAM THERE
IS ALWAYS SUCH A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LEAVE WHEN
IT'S TIME SO GO ENJOY YOUR
RETIREMENT. I THANK YOU FOR
HELPING MAKE MY EXPERIENCE AS A
CHAIRPERSON EDUCATION A MUCH
BETTER ONE AND WE WISH YOU THE
BEST THANK YOU. SENATOR JONES.
IF YOU ARE PRESIDENT JUST WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. RECOGNIZE
ROGER MACK INSTANCE RETIREMENT-
THIS MORNING. FOR MANY OF OUR
OFFICES ROGER WAS THE FIRST
STOP. WHEN WE ARE ASKED TO SPEAK
TO LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS EDUCATORS
ARE PARENT GROUPS. TWO MONTHS
AGO ROGER RECEIVED HIS- FRAME
SENATE RESOLUTION. ROGER DO YOU
HAVE IT UP THERE. WHICH IS A
GREAT- PARTING GIFT FROM THE
SENATE. ON ROGERS WHEN ASSEMBLY
HALF OF ALL THE SENATORS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF WITH WHOM
YOU'VE WORKED. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. SENATORS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
ROGER AMERICANS AND WELCOME TO
HIS WIFE KAREN ALSO THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
RETIREMENT- ROGER MALCOLMSON AND
DOUBT YOU WILL BE SORELY MISSED
. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO DO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES WERE GONNA DEFERRED THAT
TILL AFTER CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
MOVING ON THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS ITEM NUMBER ONE SENATOR
LAYERED IS READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOR
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR LAYERED AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS IN DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE AT STANFORD TO
MEDIUM LENGTH CENTER LEARN THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. A SENATE BILL FOR
EIGHTEEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS.
THAT WHEN IT SAYS URGENCY THIS
IS URGENCY WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL
WAS ONE OF TWO FOUR. LISTEN CRUZ
CA. IT SERVES A DISADVANTAGED
VALERIE AND COMMUNITY. IN THE
AREA THAT WILL BE COVERED BY
THIS DISTRICT. THERE ARE OVER
80% STUDENTS IN THE SCHOOLS OF
FREE AND REDUCED MEALS 35%
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS. OVER
80% LATINO POPULATION. IN
NOVEMBER THE HOSPITAL ANNOUNCED
IT WOULD CLOSE IN TWO WEEKS AND
THEN SENT TO THE- LAYOFF NOTICES
THERE ARE SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES OF THIS HOSPITAL
INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED PHYSICIANS
. UGH IT IS NOW GONE INTO
BANKRUPTCY IT HAS EXTENDED THE
DATE OF CLOSURE. TILL THE END OF
MARCH AND AN ORGANIZATION HAS
FORMED FROM REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ CITY OF
WATSONVILLE SALUTE PUT.
COMMUNITY HEALTH TRUSTS
SUPPORTED BY MONTEREY COUNTY
SUPPORTED BY EVERY INSTITUTION
THAT IS RELEVANT IN THE REGION.
TO FORM A HOSPITAL DISTRICT THIS
BILL. WAS JUST AMENDED TWO WEEKS
AGO IN THE ASSEMBLY AND HAS
MOVED AT LIGHTNING SPEED TO SET
UP THE HOSPITAL DISTRICT SO THAT
IN MID FEBRUARY THE BID CAN BE
MADE TO PURCHASE THE HOSPITAL
FROM THE BANKRUPTCY COURT-
BECAUSE- IT WAS CONCURRENCE.
THEY COULD ONLY BE AMENDED IN
THE ASSEMBLY SO. OUR GOVERNMENT
FINANCES ARE COMMITTEE REQUESTED
AN AMENDMENT THAT. IF FOR THIS
HOSPITAL SOLD THE DISTRICT
COURTS OUT OF BUSINESS IF THE
HOSPITALS AND PURCHASED IT WOULD
GO OUT OF BUSINESS THAT'S AN
AMENDMENT THAT WAS REQUESTED. BY
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT. IT WE
HAVE COMMITTED TO A FOLLOW UP
BILL IF IT TURNS OUT THERE
REPORTS NEEDED THERE BEEN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION SENT
EACH COUNTY. THEY WANT THIS BILL
TO MOVE BUT THERE'S A COMMITMENT
TO ADDRESS ANY TWEAKS AFTERWARDS
THUS FAR. OF THIS BILL HAD
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN VOTE IN
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN VOTE ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN VOTE IN THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
HERE IN THE SENATE. THERE IS
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES THIS BILL
IS URGENTLY NEEDED TO GET TO THE
GOVERNOR TODAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SINGMAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS. BACKER I
PORCHES I CABALLERO AYE FOR. AYE
DALLY AYE DODD. I TORONTO I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL. HI FOR
TORONTO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I ALSO AGO HI
PAM. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE WHITE HOUSE THREE FIVE
WIENER. I WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
GONZALEZ NUMBER. FIVE THIRTY
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
CONCORDANT MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO SENATE THIRD READING
ITEMNUMBER FOUR SENATOR PAN IS
READY. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY
FOUR BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR SENATOR PENN
FLOORS ACRES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS AS CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE POCKETS
IT'S MY HONOR TO PRESENT THIS
ARE SIXTY FOUR IN RECOGNITION OF
LUNAR NEW YEAR. IT'S GREAT TO
SEE EVERYONE WEARING RED TODAY
ALTHOUGH I KNOW WE HAVE MULTIPLE
REASONS FOR DOING THAT TODAY.
THIS YEAR LUNAR NEW YEAR WHICH
BEGAN ON FEBRUARY FIRST IS
WELCOMING IN THE YEAR OF THE
TIGER. THE TIGER IS THE THIRD
ANIMAL OF THE ZODIAC AND THE
SEEN AS A SYMBOL OF STRENGTH AND
COURAGE THAT WORDS OFF EVIL.
THOSE WERE BORN IN THE YEAR OF
THE TIGER SEEN AS BRAVE AND
CONFIDENT. TOO MANY ASIAN
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA LUNAR
NEW YEAR IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOLIDAYS OF THE YEAR
REPRESENTS LONGSTANDING CULTURAL
TRADITIONS. THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
HAS BEEN CELEBRATED FOR
CENTURIES BY VARIOUS ASIAN
CULTURES AND THE FIRST RECORDED
LUNAR NEW YEAR CELEBRATION
UNITED STATES WAS I SAN
FRANCISCO ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIRST EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. LIKE
MOST NEW YEAR'S THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR SIGNIFIES NEW BEGINNINGS
AND USUALLY CELEBRATED BY GRAND
PARADES FIREWORKS AND LOTS OF
FOOD DEFINITELY LOTS OF FOOD.
FOR THE EIGHTY AYE COMMUNITY
THESE PAST FEW YEARS HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT THE
CHANCE FOR NEW BEGINNINGS BRINGS
MORE THAN CELEBRATION. ALSO
BRINGS HOPE AND JOY AT A TIME WE
NEED IT MOST. ALTHOUGH MANY
FAMILIES TO ONCE AGAIN CELEBRATE
IN THEIR OWN HOUSEHOLDS WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO SHARE SOME OF THE
TRADITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH. THE
NEW YEAR. AT PRESENT MAY I USE A
PROP. YOU MAY THANK YOU. IF YOU
EACH CAME IN EACH OF YOU SHOULD
HAVE RECEIVED A LONG BOW OR READ
ON BELOW IN A LUNAR NEW YEAR
CALENDAR. IF YOU CAME. EACH RED
ENVELOPE CONTAINS A GOLD
CHOCOLATE COIN IS A LONG
STANDING TRADITION THAT WHICH IS
GOOD FORTUNE AND LOCK FOR THOSE
WHO RECEIVE THE ENVELOPE. YOU'LL
ALSO SEE THE CHINESE CHARACTER
FU PRINT PRINTED ON THE ENVELOPE
WHICH MEANS GOOD FORTUNE.
BLESSINGS OR LOCK. THIS
CHARACTERS COMMONLY SEEN ON
DOORS AND WINDOWS AND OTHER NEW
YEAR DECORATIONS TO BRING PEACE
AND FORTUNE INTO THE HOUSEHOLD.
WE ALSO HOPE YOU ENJOY FINDING
YOUR ZODIAC ON THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR CALENDAR AND CELEBRATE IT
FOR MANY YEARS TO COME. I KNOW
THAT- WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
COME TOGETHER FOR MANY EVENTS
BUT- HOPEFULLY YOU CAN VIRTUALLY
CELEBRATE WITH YOUR COMMUNITY-
THE NEW YEAR AND AS WE BRING IN-
THE YEAR OF THE TIGER. I INVITE
YOU TO WEAR SOME RED FOR GOOD
LUCK THANK YOU. AND ORDER SOME
DUMPLINGS AND NOODLES- MEANING
BOTH PROSPERITY AND LONG LIFE.
FROM YOUR LOCAL ASIAN RESTAURANT
TO CELEBRATE THE NEW YEAR. SO
PLEASE JOIN THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND WISHING EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HEALTHY PROSPEROUS.
AND FORTUNATE NEW YEAR AND
ESPECIALLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SR SIXTY FOUR. I SHOULDN'T
QUALIFY. SENATOR WIENER. I THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TOYS ARISES
AS VICE CHAIR OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND AS A SENATOR
WHO REPRESENTS NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS OF OUR
API- COMMUNITIES- TO SUPPORT SR
SIXTY FOUR AND TO WHICH EVERYONE
A VERY VERY- HAPPY AND HEALTHY
AND PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR AS WE
ENTER THE YEAR OF THE TIGER-
THIS IS BEEN A VERY VERY
CHALLENGING FEW YEARS FOR OUR
API COMMUNITIES. I LOOK AT A
COMMUNITY- THAT HAS- BEEN
SCAPEGOATED AND CLAIMS FOR
SUPPOSEDLY CAUSING. COVER
NINETEEN WITH. THIS IS LIKE A
THE CHINESE FLEW CLINICAL AND
QUOTE UNQUOTE CONSUL- AND THESE
WORDS OF CONSEQUENCES AND WE'VE
SEEN AN UPTICK. IN HATE CRIMES
AND VIOLENT ATTACKS ON OUR API
COMMUNITIES IN MY OWN COMMUNITY
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND- IN VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE STATE- STEMMING
FROM A LONG HISTORY FRANKLY OF-
INGRAINED RACISM AGAINST- R. V.
P. I. NEIGHBORS AND- STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOING BACK TO THE
EARLY DAYS. OF OUR STATE- AND
YET OUR API COMMUNITIES ARE
INCREDIBLY STRONG AND RESILIENT-
IT WAS GREAT TO BE BACK IN
SERVICES GOING ON TUESDAY TO
CELEBRATE LUNAR NEW YEAR- WITH
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY I'M
LOOKING FORWARD. TO THE RETURN
OF OUR CHINESE NEW YEAR PARADE
IN A FEW WEEKS- AND SO AS WE
START TAKING SOME STEPS TO- WE
HOPE MOVE PASS IS TERRIBLE. A
PANDEMIC UNDER THE NEW YEAR IS
ONE MORE I THINK SIGNIFICANT
MILESTONE I'LL BE CELEBRATE
TOGETHER- AND TO WORK TOGETHER
FOR A BETTER FUTURE SO. CAN HAVE
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND ADDS CHEER THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I JUST
WANT TO LEND MY VOICE IN SUPPORT
OF OUR SIXTY FOUR. THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR HOLIDAYS CELEBRATED IN MANY
ASIAN COUNTRIES AND ACROSS THIS
NATION WITH ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION PEOPLE TAKING PART IN
THE FESTIVITIES THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE THE MULTITUDE OF
CULTURES. AREA AND- THAT A CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME I SHOULD CHECK
CALIFORNIA IS THE HOME OF NEARLY
SIX MILLION ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN. IT'S
CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS SOCIAL
CULTURAL CIVIC ECONOMIC AND
ACADEMIC SUCCESS IN THE STATE
pYEAR TRADITIONALLY FOCUSES ON
THEMES OF REUNION WHOLE IN
PUTTING THE PAST BEHIND YOU. AND
LOOKING FOR YOUR FRESH AND
BRIGHT START. SOME HOLIDAY
PRACTICES INCLUDE LIGHTING
FIRECRACKERS AND DECORATING WITH
THE COLOR RED. FALKIRK'S CHANGE
RED ENVELOPES FILLED WITH LUCKY
CATS CAUGHT HUNG BOB DOLE BY
AVAILABLE. EACH YEAR IS IT
REPRESENTED BY A CYCLE ONE OF
TWELVE ZODIAC ANIMALS THIS YEAR
STATED IS THE YEAR OF THE TIGER
THE DUGGARS ARE PROBLEMS SYMBOL
UP TO NOT SLEEP AND STRESS. I
USE THAT ARE REFLECTED IN THE
HEARTS OF ALL ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICANS. WHAT THIS
RESOLUTION THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
EXPERIENCE ART THANKS TO THE
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES AND WE SHARE AND
CELEBRATING ITS NEW YEAR WITH
YOU YOUR FAMILIES AND YOUR
FRIENDS. HI BERKELEY I SWEAR I
VOTE ON SR SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU
. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I ALSO STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SR SIXTY
FOUR. AND DOC COMMAND TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I HAPPEN
TO REPRESENT A LARGE GROUP OF
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS AND I
HAVE LEARNED SO MUCH FROM THEM
AND I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO
PARTAKE IN SO MANY OTHER AMAZING
CELEBRATIONS INSTANCE GROW A
GOOD WAY TO LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER AND- MORE PARTY POLICIES
TRADITIONS TO THE NEXT
GENERATION. ARGUED NEED TO
CONTINUE THESE TRADITIONS HI I
WON TO ALSO THANK MY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS FOR ALL THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT HAVE HELPED
BUILD THIS COUNTRY THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
OFTEN GO OUT UNNOTICED BUT I
WANT TO THANK THE- COMMUNITY FOR
STANDING TOGETHER WITH ALL OF US
IN MAKING THIS COUNTRY GREAT. I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT WE SUPPORT
THEM STRONGLY ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS TIME WHERE WE SEE A LOT OF
ANTI ASIAN HATE CRIMES HAPPENING
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND THERE IS NO
PLACE FOR THAT AND WE CONTINUE
TO RE COMMIT OURSELVES TO
STANDING TOGETHER FIGHTING HATE
CRIMES AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY- FEEL SUPPORTED AND ALSO
WELCOME. SO THIS NEW YEAR I ALSO
WANT US TO RECOMMIT TO
SUPPORTING SPEAKING OUT AND
BEING STRONG ADVOCATES FOR THEM
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES AS WE
CELEBRATE WE WANT TO ALSO
ENCOURAGE THAT WE SHOP LOCAL.
THAT WE FIND OUR THE NEAREST API
RESTAURANT SHOP LET'S SUPPORT
HIM AS WELL BY BY GOING INTO
THEIR BUSINESSES AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY KNOW THAT WE CARE WE
WELCOME THEM AND WE WANT TO BE
PART. OF EVERYTHING THAT THEY
HAVE TO OFFER AND WITH THAT I
ALSO ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. CENTER DRAWS A- THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS- I RISE WITH GREAT
PLEASURE IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
SIXTY FOUR ALL ACROSS OUR GREAT
AND DIVERSE STATE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS OF MANY BACKGROUNDS
AND NATIONALITIES WILL RING IN
THIS IMPORTANT TO OUT TIME AND
CELEBRATE THE YEAR OF THE TIGER
THIS RICH CULTURAL HOLIDAYS
FILLED WITH SO MANY TRADITIONS.
THEY'RE ROOTED IN THE HOLE FOR
GOOD FORTUNE AND PROSPERITY SAYS
WE WISH WISHY TO THEIR
PROSPERITY HEALTH AND SUCCESS
BUT IS GO BEYOND THE INDIVIDUAL
LOUIS COMMITTEES NEW DAY TO THE
PROSPERITY AND SUCCESS OF OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY A NEW DAY IN
WHICH WILL ENSURE OUR SENIORS
DON'T FEAR EVICTIONS AND HAVE A
SECURE INCOME TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES A NEW DAY IN WHICH
OUR YOUTH CAN REACH THEIR DREAMS
AND ASPIRATIONS. THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
LEAVE THEM IN DEBT FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES A NEW DAY IN
WHICH WE TAKE CARE OF OUR
PLANET'S AIR WATER AND LAND FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS AND A NEW DAY
. FOR OUR IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO FEAR BEING
RIPPED FROM THE ARMS OF THE
PARENTS. AND ALL PEOPLE ARE
RESPECTED NO MATTER WHERE THEY
WERE BORN THEIR FAITH OR WHAT
LANGUAGE THEY SPEAK. A NEW DAY
FOR ALL OF HUMANITY. I AM PROUD
THAT IN MY OWN DISTRICT- IT
INCLUDES MANY HISTORICALLY
RECOGNIZED ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THAI TOWN
KOREA TOWN. CHINATOWN LITTLE
TOKYO FILIPINO TOWN AND LITTLE
BANGLADESH. I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL
TO FIND THE LOCAL NEW YEAR
CELEBRATION WITH IN PERSON-
VIRTUALLY- AND TAKE IN ALL THAT
IT'S ABOUT HOLD. GOOD HEALTH
SUCCESS AND PROSPERITY I JOIN
THE API CAUCUS IN MOTION OUR
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS. A HAPPY
NEW LUNAR NEW YEAR THANK YOU.
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GUNG HAY FAT CHOY
HAPPY NEW YEAR COLLEAGUES- AS
THE SENATE OTHER REPRESENTATIVE. SUPPORT OF S. R. SIXTY FOUR AS
IT'S BEEN EXPRESSED THE LUNAR
NEW YEAR IS IT REALLY IMPORTANT
HOLIDAY FOR ASIAN CULTURES
AROUND THE WORLD AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY APPROPRIATE THAT
THIS IS THE YEAR OF THE TIGER I
WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO MY SON
TEDDY WHO WAS BORN TWELVE YEARS
AGO IN THE LAST YEAR OF THE
TIGER- IN THE TIGERS WE KNOW
REPRESENTS THE VALUES OF COURAGE
INDEPENDENCE AND HAVING A STRONG
SENSE OF JUSTICE AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT AS
WE- CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH
KOBE. AND AN ALARMING RISE IN
HATE INCLUDING ANTI ASIAN HATE
THAT CONTINUES TO REAR ITS UGLY
HEAD THAT WE EMBODY THE VALUES
OF THE TIGER THIS YEAR LET'S
STAND UP LET'S BE FEARLESS AND
SHOWING OUR COMPASSION AND
RESOLVE FOR OTHERS AND SHOWING
THE CALIFORNIA IS A PLACE THAT
DECISIVELY REJECTS HEY THAT
STANDS UP FOR THE VALUES OF
COMPASSION. WITH OVER SIX
MILLION A NEARLY SIX MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BY
FAR THE LARGEST ASIAN API
POPULATION. IN THE COUNTRY I'M
PLEASED TO BE IN ORANGE COUNTY
WHERE WE HAVE ALMOST SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND ASIAN AMERICANS
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS INCLUDING
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. IN
THE DISTRICT THAT I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING. SO
COME ON OUT TO IRVINE SOMETIMES
LET'S CELEBRATE IF YOU AYE
CULTURE. ALL RIGHTS AND SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE OUR STATE'S RICH
CULTURAL HISTORY. AND COMMITMENT
TO RACIAL RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL
DIVERSITY. SO LET'S FIND
STRENGTH AND HAPPINESS WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND FOR MY FAMILY TO
YOURS I WISH YOU ALL HAPPINESS
HEALTH AND PROSPERITY DURING
THIS NEW YEAR. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE AS WELL IN
SUPPORT OF TERRORIST RESOLUTION
SIXTY FOUR CELEBRATING THE LNAR
NEW YEAR I HAVE THE HONOR OF
REPRESENTING THE SENATE DISTRICT
WHICH INCLUDES THE SOUTHEASTERN
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY IN WHICH HAS
AMONG THE HIGHEST NUMBER AND
MOST DIVERSE NUMBER OF API
RESIDENTS MANY DISTRICT ARE
GREAT STATE I WANT TO WISH
JOINING WISHING ALL OF MY
FRIENDS IN THE ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES A
VERY HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR AS WE
CELEBRATE THE YEAR OF THE TIGER
- AS NOTED THE TIGER SYMBOLIZES
COURAGE AMBITION AND GENERASI
QUALITIES. THAT THE ASIAN
AMERICANS PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
EMBODY ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
MISDIRECTED HOSTILITY AND
FRICTION- THAT HAVE BEEN
SURPRISED OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS. THERE'S ALSO NOTED-
TIGERS ARE TENACIOUS WHEN FACED
WITH ADVERSITY SOMETHING EACH OF
US HAS BEEN CALLED ON TO BE
WILLING DURING. THE HISTORIC
CHALLENGES OF THE PAST TWO YEARS
MADE THIS COMING LUNAR NEW YEAR
BE FILLED WITH GOOD FORTUNE.
HEALTH FELLOWSHIP AND PROSPERITY
AS WE CONTINUE OUR VERY
IMPORTANT WORK HERE. ON THEIR
BEHALF I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION. GENUINE CHRYSLER
SHISHA THANK YOU. SENATOR EGGMAN. AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ALSO
RISE AS A CARE OF VICE CHAIR OF
THE LGBT CAUCUS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. SIXTY FOUR
BY THE LGBT CAUCUS IS THE ONE
THAT IS HE MOST INCLUSIVE I
WOULD SAY WE GET TO STAND UP BUT
WE GOT BECAUSE WE HAVE A P. I.
MEMBERS WE HAVE LATINO MEMBERS
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS WITH WELL WE
HAVE A- IN IN NOT AND NAZARIAN
OUR CAUCUS PRESENTLY. BUT I JUST
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE E. P. I. COMMUNITY AND THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR AND THE
IMPORTANCE THAT THEY HAVE HAD IN
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR CULTURE OUR
FOOD IN EVERY PART OF US AND SO
AS WE LIKE TO CELEBRATE PEOPLE
IN THEIR CULTURAL IT'S ALSO NOT
JUST CELEBRATE BUT BUT HONOR AND
RESPECT THE TENANTS THAT GO
ALONG WITH THAT- IN MY DISTRICT
OF STOCKTON AND SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY WILL HAVE A VERY. LARGE
API COMMUNITY BOTH SOUTHEAST
ASIANS CAMBODIANS AND VIETNAMESE
A AND ONE OF THE OLDEST-
FILIPINO COMMUNITIES IN THE IN
THE COUNTRY AND THE LARGEST IN
THE COUNTRY AT ONE TIME AS WELL
AS OUR OUR JAPANESE AND- THE
CITY OF LOCK THAT THE SENATOR
DODD NIGHT SOMEWHAT SHARE THE
FIRST ONLY CHINESE
ESTABLISHMENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS STILL THERE IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE A VITAL ON THE
DELTA SEE THAT BEAUTIFUL
HISTORIC TOWN OF LAC WHEN THE
CHINESE OFTEN WEREN'T ALLOWED TO
LIVE WITH OTHERS BUT WERE
INVITED TO DO ALL OF THE WORK-
AND JUST AS AN ASIDE. I DON'T IT
TO ANYBODY HASN'T SEEN A DONUT
KING YET IT'S A FANTASTIC MOVIE
ABOUT THE CAMBODIAN IMMIGRANT
EXPERIENCE- AND THE IMPACT ON
ON- JUST THE INGENUITY AND HARD
WORK OF FOLKS SO AS WE CELEBRATE
THIS YEAR THE TIGER THE LGBT
CAUCUS RIGHT AND THEN PROUD
SUPPORT. OF THE EMBRACING OF THE
API COMMUNITY AS. IT INTERSECTS
WITH OURS THANK YOU. SENATOR
NIELSEN. MAN PRESS LADIES THIS I
RISE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS RED
. IT'S OF OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
YET AGAIN IT KNOWLEDGE THE
IMPACT. THEIR AGENT PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY AND HISTORY
OF CALIFORNIA. JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO WE HAD A VERY SPECIAL YEAR
LONG CELEBRATION OF THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
COMPLETION OF THE INTERNET
INTERCONTINENTAL RAILROAD. AND
OUR CHINESE COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY HAVE PLAYED A MAJOR
DECISIVE ROLE. IN LINKING THE
EAST COAST TO THE WEST COAST-
THAT TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD.
COMING HERE FROM CHINA TO WORK.
IN IN THE HARDEST HIT AREAS TO
WORK CROSSING THE SHARES. MANY
LIVES WERE LOST. OVER THE MANY
DECADES SO MANY HAVE SETTLED
HERE. THE END OF THE WAR IN THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA SO MANY SOUTHEAST
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS CAME
. CALIFORNIA TO SERVE. MANY IN
THE SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEYS. THAT A. B. IS A LITTLE
KNOWN FACT. WHEN PEOPLE THINK OF
THE API COMMUNITY THEY TEND TO
THINK OF THE BIG CITIES. THEY'RE
ALWAYS THERE BUT WE HAVE HUGE
ENCLAVES. OF THAT ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS THROUGH OUR VALLEY
COUNTIES. ONE OF MARILYN MY
DEAREST FRIENDS MISTER CC
WRITTEN IN. FROM BACK AVAIL. IS
THE FOUNDER OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ASSOCIATION. IT'S NOW A
NATIONWIDE ORGANIZATION WITH I
THINK ABOUT THIRTY FIVE CHAPTERS
. AND OUR PURPOSE IN A PAPA THE
CALLER THE PAPA. IS TO PROMOTE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. API CITIZENS
TO PARTICIPATE. TO BE AWARE OF
AND THE PROSPECT. IN OUR BODY
POLITIC. WE HAVE INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS WE HAVE SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS IN A VOTER FOR. EVERY
OTHER YEAR. AND IT DOESN'T
KNOWLEDGE THE CONTRIBUTION. THE
API FOLKS OF MAY. INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH I'M ONE OF THE SIX
ORIGINAL FOUNDERS IF YOU WILL.
SIX OF US SET DOWN IN A SMALL
OFFICE FROM TWENTY ONE YEARS
AGO. AND TALKED ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING BOULDERS THIS. I STILL
AM INVOLVED BUT MORE INVOLVED IS
MY WIFE MARYLAND. WHO IS
INTERNATIONAL EXECUTIVE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE POP. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN TO GIVE THEM THIS
RECOGNITION. AND ALSO. JOIN WITH
ME SHORTLY- PREPARING
LEGISLATION AT THE REQUEST OF
THE PAPA. TO INCORPORATE SOME
EDUCATIONAL. CURRICULA IN OUR
SCHOOLS ABOUT THIS VERY HISTORY
WE CELEBRATE HERE TODAY THE
IMPACT THE API COMMUNITY. IN
CALIFORNIA AND AMERICA. IT'S NOT
A MAJOR MANDATE ON OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. BUT IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER
COMMUNICATE TO OUR USE. ABOUT
THEIR FUTURE AND THE
PARTICIPATION THE API COMMUNITY
I URGE AN IDOL. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IS THE CHAIR OF
MILITARY VETERANS COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT OF SR SIXTY FOUR. AND
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE MEN
AND WOMEN. FROM THE API
COMMUNITY WHO SERVED THIS GREAT
COUNTRY AND THEY SERVED WITH
HONOR DISTINCTION ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE CALL OF DUTY IN SOME
CASES. AND I HAVE TO ASK ALL OF
US REFLECT BACK TO WORLD WAR
TWO. WHEN IT NEEDS SAY WERE
ASKED TO JOIN THE MILITARY THEY
CAME IN DROVES TO JOIN AND BE
PART. OF THE FOUR FORTY SECOND
REGIMENTAL COMBAT TEAM THAT
DISTINGUISH ITSELF IN EUROPE
WITH COMBAT RECEIVING FOUR
MEDALS AND DECORATIONS AND
WOUNDED THAN ANY OTHER UNIT IN
THE UNITED STATES ARMY. THEY
TRULY BELIEVED IN AMERICA AND
FELT THAT GIVING OF THEIR LIVES
GIVING OF THEMSELVES WOULD PROVE
THAT THEY ARE. DESERVING TO BE
CALLED AMERICANS. AND NOW WE
FIND OURSELVES CELEBRATING THE
KNOWLEDGE IN ALL THESE YEARS
LATER. THE FACT THAT THE API
COMMUNITY HAS CONTRIBUTED SO
MUCH TO THIS GREAT COUNTRY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR PERSEVERANCE
IN EDUCATION AND HARD WOR. THE
FAMILY VALUES WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN THEY COME
TOGETHER THEY COME TOGETHER AS
AMERICANS WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
HIM. AS AMERICANS AND I SO PROUD
AND HONORED IN MY DISTRICT THE
THIRTY SECOND SENATE DISTRICT
WE'VE GOT THE SHIITE TEMPLE A
BEAUTIFUL TEMPLE. PEOPLE TO THIS
BEAUTIFUL TEMPLE THAT WE HAVE
HERE KNOWLEDGE IN OUR
GOVERNMENT. AND I INVITE
EVERYONE WHO'D LIKE TO COME TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO COME TO
THE COMMUNITY OF HACIENDA
HEIGHTS AND SEE THIS MONUMENT
ONE MONUMENT. TO THE- API
COMMUNITY IT IS BEAUTIFUL AND I
THANK THE SENATORS AND EVERYONE
SENATOR PAN AND THAT OUR LAND OF
CALL YOU UP PERSONALLY. AND
THANK YOU FOR REPRESENTING YOUR
COMMUNITIES IF THE AUDIBLE IF
YOU DO. AND I ASK US TO HONOR S.
R. SIXTY FOUR NOT JUST TODAY BUT
EVERYDAY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. FOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE. SINGMAN
SENATOR PAN YOU MAY CONCLUDE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT
JUST THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES- SO
MUCH FOR SPEAKING OUT AND IN
FAVOR THIS RESOLUTION AND- I
ALSO WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
JOINING IN CELEBRATIONS
CELEBRATING THE LUNAR NEW YEAR.
I DO WANT TO CONCLUDE- ALSO BY
RECOGNIZING MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SAN FRANCISCO WHO ACTUALLY LED
THE CHARGE TO BE SURE THAT OUR
STATE RECOGNIZES LUNAR NEW YEAR
IS A DAY OF SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE
AND THAT WAS PASSED INTO LAW-
BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY NINETEEN- SO AGAIN-
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN JOIN OUR API
COMMUNITY IN OUR CELEBRATIONS-
GO OUT ENJOY SOME GREAT ASIAN
FOOD- AND HAVE IT BRING YOU.
PROSPERITY HEALTH AND GOOD
FORTUNE FOR THIS COMING YEAR.
YEAH AND JENNA KAILA THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND IT WOULD RESPECT
ASPEN IDEAS THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS RECALL SEEING MAN FIVE
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION AND IT IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON BACK
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES IS THERE ANYONE WHO HAS
A MOTION RESOLUTION OR A NOTICE.
YES SENATOR MELENDEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY EIGHT I MAKING A
MOTION TO WITHDRAW AS YOUR FIVE
FROM THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE HAVE IT
BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO
WE CAN HAVE A FULL. AND VIGOROUS
DEBATE SENATORS I THINK YOUR
CONSTITUENTS MY CONSTITUENTS
DESERVE TO KNOW WHERE WE STAND
ON CONTINUING THIS SUPPOSE ED
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN ALLOWING A
VOTE ON S. C. R. FIVE DOES NOT
MEAN YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT CO
BID. IT MEANS YOU CARE ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS SO ONCE AGAIN. BY
MAKING THE MOTION TO HAVE THIS
BILL BROUGHT. OUT FOR A VOTE. I
HOPE THAT YOU. CONSIDER CHANGING
YOUR VOTE TO AN AYE VOTE. THIS
TIME THIS IS THE MILLIONS TIME I
THINK THAT I'VE- MADE THIS
MOTION- BUT. UNLIKE MERRY
GARCETTI I WILL NOT HOLD MY
BREATH THANK YOU. SENATE MCGUIRE
. THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO VOTE. CENTER MELENDEZ
ASPIRIN I WROTE SENATOR MCGUIRE
ASTRONOVA PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN NO ARCHULETA. NO ATKINS.
BAKER NO PORCHES I CABALLERO NO
CORTELLI. CORTESE NO VALLEY I
DON NO TORONTO NO EGGMAN NO
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ HERTZBERG NO
WESA. NO PATADA NO JONES I
KAMLAGER NO LAYERED NO LEYVA
NOPE THE MON. NO MCGUIRE. NO
MELENDEZ FIVE MEN. NO NEWMAN NO
NIELSEN FIVE A TO A VOTE. HI PAM
NO PORTANTINO NO ROTH NO RUBIO.
NO SKINNER. NO STERN NO I'M
BURKE WHITE HOUSE SKI NO WIENER. NO WELL HI. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS GONZALEZ
NUMBER. NO SEVEN FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN MEAN HAVE. I MODE I SEVEN
KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN MOTION FAILS
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY MORE-
NOTICES OR OR MOTIONS. CENTER
GLACIER- PRIVILEGES THE FLOOR
MADAM CHAIR YES WILL MOVE ON TO
PRIVILEGES AT THE FLOOR SENATOR
MEMBERS AYE I HUMBLY APPEAR
BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS. THE REALLY
INCREDIBLE ATHLETIC EVENT THAT
WE ALL WITNESSED LAST SUNDAY. IT
WAS A SUPER COMPETITION OF TWO
GREAT CALIFORNIA TEAMS. AND I AM
HERE TO SAY AND OFFER UP MY
GREATEST CONGRATULATIONS TO THE
FANS HERE ON THE FLOOR AND IN
OUR STATE FOR THE WINNING LOS
ANGELES RAMS- THE SAN FRANCISCO
FORTY NINERS. ARE ALSO A
WONDERFUL TEAM DID THEIR BEST
BUT THE RESULTS ON THE FIELD ARE
THE RESULTS THAT I WITH
KNOWLEDGE AND WE CONGRATULATE I
KNOW THAT AS THE RAMS ADVANCE TO
THE SUPERBOWL THAT WE AS
CALIFORNIANS WILL ALL JOIN
TOGETHER IN- WISHING THEM. THE
BEST- IN THAT CONTEST I KNOW
THAT WE CAN BE TOGETHER
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS AND
OTHERS- AND URGING A SUCCESSFUL
RESOLUTION OF THAT CONTEST- A
MERE TEN DAYS FROM NOW SO WITH
THAT MEMBERS GRADUATIONS TO THE
RAMS AND ALL THEIR FANS HERE IN
OUR STATE. MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE
. SENATORS SKINNER. THANK YOU
THE- BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL MEET
FIVE AFTER THE FLOOR HAS BEEN
CLEANED APPOINTED GERMAN. IN THE
ON THE FLOOR. VERY GOOD CENTER
EGGMAN THANK YOU IN THAT ONE
THIRTY SENATE SUB BY BUDGET SUB
THREE WILL MEET IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SO NOTED SENATOR STERN.
YOU HAVE A COMMITTEE MEETING
TODAY. YES SIR OUR BUDGET- JOINT
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO BE MEETING THIS
AFTERNOON- WHEN WE CHECK THE
DESK REQUEST WITH WHICH OUR TIME
. OKAY AT ONE O'CLOCK IN THE
CHAMBERS VERY GOOD APOLOGIES ONE
O'CLOCK IN THE CHAMBERS FOR THE
JOINT EMERGENCY LEGISLATIVE
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE SO NOTED.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
CENTER MCGUIRE THE DESK IS CLEAR
. THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENTE GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE
WORK THIS WEEK THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
PM IN WHICH TIME THE GERMAN
MOTION BE PLACE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM.